[موسيقى]
بحث البشر عبر الازمنه عن الماء وجعلوه
سببا في ارتحالهم او استقرارهم حتى بداوا
في ايجاد طرق مختلفه لتخزينه بناء السدود
كان احدها لكنها لم تستخدم لهذه الغايه
فقط بل اصبحت جزءا لا يتجزا من المجتمعات
المتقدمه فكيف حدث هذا ربما كان سكان
بلادما بين النهرين القدماء من اوائل من
بنى السدود فاقدم سد معروف هو سد جاوا
الذي تم بناؤه من الحصى والصخور بالقرن
الرابع قبل الميلاد في الاردن بلغ ارتفاعه
15 قدما وكان يتسع لنحو مليون ومئه الف
قدم مكعب فشكل انجازا معماريا انذاك مع
مميزات امان مبتكره جعلته قائما حتى سنوات
قليله مضت حيث دمر جزئيا
وفر هذا السد للمزارعين مصدرا ثابتا
للمياه لري المحاصيل وسد احتياجات السكان
الغذائيه بمنطقه ما بين النهرين
شهدت الحضارات اللاحقه تجارب متفاوته
النجاح ببناء السدود فبعد ما يقرب من 400
عام من بناء سد جاوا بنى المصريون سد
الكفاره لكنه جرف اثناء هطول الامطار
الغزيره ولم يتم اصلاحه او استكماله
الرومان بدورهم استفادوا من تقدمهم في
الهندسه الهيدروليكيه فبنوا سدود الجاذبيه
كسدود سوبياكو وهي ثلاثه سدود على نهر
انيان الايطالي بلغ حينها ارتفاع اكبرها
165 قدما واعتبر الاطول بالعالم الى ان تم
تدميره في عام
1305 بالمقابل بقي سد الجاذبيه الروماني
كورنالفو يمد سكان مارذه باسبانيا بالمياه
حتى اليوم في القرن الاول قبل الميلاد شيد
الرومان ايضا سد غلانوم وهو اول سد قوسي
في العالم كما بنوا اول سدود دعامه في
العالم بشبه الجزيره الايبيريه في فتره ما
قبل الميلاد باربع مئه عام بنى الاسيويون
سدودا ترابيه لتخزين المياه لمدن سريلانكا
الحديثه في القرن الخامس الميلادي بنى
السنغاليون العديد من السدود التي لا تزال
الاستخدام حتى اليوم وفي القرن الثاني عشر
الميلادي تقريبا تم بناء نحو 4000 سد من
قبل الحاكم السنهالي باركراما بابو لاهداف
استعراضيه حيث لم تكن تزود القرى بالمياه
اسهمت اليابان والهند ايضا في هندسه
السدود المبكره حتى اليوم فلا تزال خمسه
من اقدم عشره سدود في هذين البلدين قيد
الاستخدام في القرن الثاني تم بناء سد
بحيره حمص في سوريا الذي لا يزال يخدم
اهالي المنطقه حتى اليوم قبل ان يتقلص
بناء السدود خلال العصور المظلمه ويستانف
في القرن الخامس عشر الميلادي تقريبا حيث
بنيت العديد من السدود في اوروبا
حتى خمسينيات القرن التاسع عشر لم تكن
هناك اسس هندسيه لبناء السدود الى ان جاء
استاذ الهندسه المدنيه بجامعه غلاسكو
ويليام
في تحسين فهم هندسه السدود بشكل علمي في
الفتره من
1853 حتى
1910 عمل العديد من المهندسين البريطانيين
والفرنسيين على تحسين تصميم السدود
الخرسانيه ما ساعد على التوسع ببناء
السدود فظهرت السدود الصناعيه التي
استخدمت لتشغيل الالات الكبيره للمصانع
والمناجم وتشغيل التوربينات العملاقه
لتوليد الكهرباء وغيرها
مع اوائل القرن العشرين وتزايد الطلب على
الكهرباء تم بناء السد الكبير في امريكا
كما وجه الرئيس فرانكلين روزفلت ببناء
سدود ضخمه وكان من اشهرها سده هوفر الذي
اعتبر اطول سد في ذلك الوقت بارتفاع 222
مترا في عام
1998 تم تسجيل براءه اختراع الخرسانه
الذكيه التي عملت على تطويرها الدكتوره
ديبور تشونغ المحاضره بجامعه نيويورك حيث
تم تدعيمها بالياف من الكربون لزياده
قدرتها على الاحساس بالتوتر او الاجهاد
وبالتالي تغطيه العيوب في البناء ما شكل
طفره نوعيه في بناء السدود لاحقا
شهدت الاعوام المئه الماضيه مساهمات كبيره
بهندسه السدود ومع الطلب المتزايد على
المياه والطاقه يتوقع ان تسجل المزيد من
الابتكارات
[موسيقى]